the distinct characteristic of CFI if
you think about the environment that the
executive students encounter is that I
would describe it as drastically
different experiences that fit together
remarkably well so in the morning we
have what I would describe as more
traditional analytic case style
discussion and then in the afternoon
what the students do is they the
executives of course is they go out in
teams and they study some customer
service challenge in in situ as it's
actually unfolding and they actually
develop prototypes that are evaluated by
executives from the firm's we wanted to
marry as Bob just mentioned the clean
models that we teach in the business
school with the dirty hands or the messy
hands experiences that are typical of
the design Institute we actually provide
them an out-of-the-box experienced this
year we work with the leading
multinational that's an oil company and
they have gas stations in California and
they have asked us can you actually help
us redesign the customer experience in
these gas stations well the most
creative group the idea they had was
very simple they said look you've been
looking at this as a b2c business
something where you sell to individual
consumers instead why don't you think of
it as a b2b business look at Stanford
University look at how many cars are
parked there and faculty members work
why can somebody fill gas one of the
reasons we believe the program's so
important is that the link between
serving customers well and corporate
profits and growth are obvious and
essential customers are the main sources
of income so whether you're producing
packaged goods whether you're selling a
service like like a management
consulting firm the fact is that
pleasing customers and keeping them
interested in bringing in their dollars
and attention is something that's a
concern to all organizations there's a
company I work with a lot in called IDEO
which is a product development firm and
they'll very often go into organizations
and for them the customers would be in
this case the people are stocking
shelves and they're having this problem
that they couldn't figure
why target which was the customer why
target wasn't selling enough M&Ms one of
the mottos in the program is that being
masters of the obvious is one of the
things that that great leaders and great
companies do Eminem is owned by the
Hershey corporation they don't say
Eminem's on them the boxes they say
Hershey so the people in the Target
stores there's a lot of Target stores
didn't know that there was M&Ms in those
boxes when they were out of stock they
didn't know how to restock we had two
participants from one company based in
Santa Barbara and by the way companies
send teams of participants on occasion
to the program and what these two
executives realized in the middle of the
program is by god we've got to do this
in our company and you know what they
did in the middle of the program they
called their CEO they actually rented a
warehouse to replicate exactly what we
were doing in the program and when we
spoke to executives in that company they
said this was the first time when we
felt extraordinarily confident and our
initial responses from the market
indicated that our products are going to
be very well received because they
respond to genuine customer means the
ideal candidate for the CFI program has
three characteristics the first thing is
it would be somebody who is in a
position or being close to an internal
or external customer is a big part of
their job or if they want it to be a big
part of their job and that doesn't mean
that we're just talking about people in
marketing and sales who are outward
facing very often it's actually people
in R&D and in product development the
second thing would be somebody who was
senior enough to actually have an impact
on the organization because otherwise I
think it just leads to frustration in
the third thing and probably the most
important thing this is a class that
stretches people they are not people who
just are asked to sit in the back and be
if you like Watchers of television they
have to be active participants in the
class and especially in the afternoons
when we go out and observe customers in
their roles do things like prototyping
coming with ideas developing
presentations for the executives we
bring in and if you're the kind of
person who is sort of like going to sort
of sit back and watch something happen
to
you I would advise this is not the right
program for you but if you want to get
involved get your hands dirty meet some
interesting folks this is the right
program for you
you